hey what's up party people welcome to
australia commentaries coming to you
live from the phantom studio oh wait
well sort of i'm here where are you guys
what's going on
i'm in my room
i'm in my living room and i've got like
boxes behind me that have my address on
them hence the i could move the boxes
and clean my apartment or i could just
blur the background no not not on our
account uh we do have uh um a covered
wave i'd say uh sort of sweeping
tangentially to
uh the people who work uh here so uh out
of an abundance of caution we're all in
separate locations it's like um you know
the president and the vice president and
like the speaker of the house they can't
like all be in the same place all in one
time right and out of out of fairness
this was the other roommate this time
and this is what i get for having
this is what i get for having two
roommates
yeah ryan you're like the designated
survivor yeah
if we all die you're the you're the king
is watching miss marvel in a secure
location right now in case he needs to
step up
we are here to talk about um
probably anything except stranger things
season four but that's ostensibly why
we're here because we could be on this
trailer for it um it was a long show and
we all watched it wrongly um i thought
it was pretty good but we'll get into
that later after um we watching this
trailer together we're gonna see some
deleted scenes and we will take comments
and questions from viewers like you so
keep those coming in the chat and ryan
will pass the best ones belong to me
um oh we'll also tease you with next
week episode which will be fun i'm i'm
excited for next week yeah uh strangest
things season four um look it's i
thought it was uh one of the stronger
seasons of the show
i thought it was like
i lost interest in season three but this
kind of peaked it again um and thought
okay five seasons seems about the right
amount but what can you say it's premium
mediocre television it's good mediocre
television it is my uh encapsulated
review way too long but the kids are
super charming and a lot of them are
good and
the story is good enough to keep you
watching until the next scene which is
up we lost audio
audio
he's saying you guys just keep going
guys okay great um yeah i uh agree with
a lot of that i didn't uh season three
kind of pulled me out as well like
wasn't necessarily my favorite i liked a
lot of this new season i
think one thing we definitely have to uh
just go ahead and do agree with as um
fans of the show or people who watch the
show
don't fall in love with new characters
just don't just save your heart just
don't fall in love with them um would be
would be my best advice but yeah i liked
all that stuff i liked all all the stuff
with uh with becna um
really good i loved all of the attention
that lucas got this season
um i'm glad that we got some really good
meaty things for for him to do but yeah
i mean i i don't know if i would call it
like mediocre but it's also you know i i
that this kind of uh poppy silly
um you know a big mystery
solved over the course of a season buffy
type stuff is my stuff so
can you say can you hear me now yes yeah
i said premium mediocre there's a
difference it's like it's not really
good but it's not bad so yeah i don't
know lon what do you think i mean i
think there's a thing that stranger
things does really well and then and it
continues to do that thing really well
like hitting that like
amblin stephen king 80s kids on a
mission it's creepy but it's not
disgusting or full-blown you know like i
think it it tows that line and it
continues to do a good job with that
again yeah like vector looks cool it's a
cool way to fold in like it's a little
bit of a nightmare on elm street element
there's a little bit of like a scanners
element but it feels like it's it's
grabbing from enough stuff that it
doesn't feel totally reductive but like
there's just so much fat now
like around the meat you know like i i
just feel like
their idea of how to make the show more
epic is to just pat it out with a lot of
stuff that you don't really need instead
of like actually making what happens
feel more epic and and i mean like i
think the two big examples would be
there's a very very long desert road
trip that we maybe didn't need to see
the full breadth of like i feel like we
could have skipped some utah probably
along the way maybe maybe a little north
arizona uh
and and there's a there's a long
sequence
in kimchatka at this soviet prison where
they're breaking out of the prison they
got to go back to the prison we oh we
call you you're betrayed go back to
prison and now he's out again and it's
like this is one
in and out trip i don't feel like we
need eight in and out trips there's a
lot to uh a lot to pick apart here and a
lot that i think they could have left on
the cutting room floor um same with our
honest trailer so let's roll that the
long one and we'll uh we'll stop and
start as we go fair enough
[Music]
now that their stock is in pound town
another squid game is still two years
off and you have more choices than ever
when it comes to background noise i mean
streaming services the only show keeping
netflix alive has returned i think you
should leave i don't know what to tell
you bud we're just shooting funerals and
showing the ones where the bodies fly
out
also stranger things it's still pretty
popular
we had a lot of options when it came to
uh i think you should leave clips but
you know as much as i have favorites
from season two like uh the girl who's
caught in the charlie brown leg um or
sloppy stakes as ryan's putting out i
think the most iconic one is probably
cough and flop from season two right the
most recognizable i mean
be the only other one yeah yeah the i
don't even want to be here guy
[Laughter]
yeah i think i have my other favorites
but i feel like those are the two that
have become the most like fixtures in
the internet firmament
yeah yeah and
yeah adult ghost tour that's good yeah
don't go sir i mean there's there's a
little buff boys there's a lot of great
stuff part two yeah i i thought um you
know just for an honest trailer is like
kind of more genre oriented audience the
the um
ghost of christmas future with like uh
where he's in the mech suit and oh
he's
fighting the bonies
that's season one though yeah yeah
yeah oh well um
can we just watch can we just watch did
you see that um i think you should
i think you should leave this up for
it's up for a few emmys oh good but one
of them is like best short form variety
and it's up against our old oral friends
like carpool karaoke randy rainbow it's
like this isn't it
okay you shouldn't even put tim robinson
up against randy rainbow
that's a different category of content
folks
we are the sharks in the jets with randy
ready but we're not never letting it go
i feel like even randy rainbow would be
like no come on that's like something
beyond what i'm doing
yeah
i would hope randy rainbow would have
that level of it was never quite they
never quite figured out our emmy
category because it was you know a randy
rainbow an honest trailer and then it
was like the daily show and carpool
karaoke but that's what this category is
it's like stephen colbert's tuning out
the news versus carpool karaoke versus
radio it's basically they got our spot
like tim robinson got the got the honest
trailer
fine more power he deserves it we gotta
start auto tuning that news again that's
what we're
there's only one more season until
stranger things is over and one more
year until these kids can legally drink
now the duffers are serving up 13 more
hours of 80s reference stew fast times
at ridgemont high choo choo chong's next
movie 16 candles teen wolf and romancing
the stone but since they're almost out
of stephen king to [ __ ] from
almost
they're tapping brand new sources of
nostalgia like heavy metal album covers
famous 90s movies and in some real snake
eating its own butthole moments early
seasons of stranger things
[Music]
oh stranger things i i liked that show
when i was a kid
goonies never say die
so
let's take bets right here the spin-off
because they're doing five seasons and
then they're gonna move on to something
else i would put any amount well not any
amount of money i will put bet 90 that
it's going to be set in the 90s
one way or another um
they're going to find some reason
whether the kids are grown up or
and they're flashing back to the 90s or
it's new cast in the 90s they can't do
this show without a new uh slot bucket
full of references uh that people
recognize um they can't do the 70s like
they
or the 60s or something that people
alive and know how to work netflix can
recognize so this i'm i'm putting down
my marker this will be a 90s show one
way or another what say you
i don't think that that's a bad call
like that's i could 100 say that i don't
think that that's a bad call at all
i feel like that's the obvious way to go
my my my only caveat to that is i do
think that a way to do it would be it's
already
so sort of like loosely inspired by it
that i feel like one way to do a
follow-up would be it cuts to
a generation later and it's like the
evil has returned to dawkins and at
least one or two of the adult versions
of the kids have to come back
dairy style and like we thought we'd
gotten rid of vecna before but now he's
affecting the new kids and we gotta stop
him for good and like there is such a
they love their stephen king nods and
like that is such a stephen king thing
to do that i almost feel like they hard
to resist so the spin-off is like hit
chapter god you gave me an idea though
maybe it's a it's set in the near future
and they're nostal nostalgic for the
present
they're like
randy rainbow
yeah
oh that that's actually very clever so
it's 20 30 but it's like remember dosia
cat
[Laughter]
so i'm gonna talk about that we're gonna
get into that yeah well we can you want
to talk about that now really talk about
dojo
it is literally the funniest thing in
the world so for those uh
i i'm sure that uh with this audience
there isn't going to be too much overlap
in this one
doja cat uh the the pop uh singer rapper
slid into
uh noah the kid who plays will slid into
his dms 17 year old kid to be like yo
hook me up with your friend uh eddie
and so she couldn't find the instagram
for joseph quinn who plays eddie
and so she was like how what how do i
contact him and he was like he's on
instagram and then we'll say the kid who
plays we'll send her the instagram link
but then and they do not know each other
by the way like it wasn't one of those
things where it's like they were buzz i
don't even know if they followed each
other she was just like his dm's are
open and i'm getting in them yeah
and yeah and so then he like mentioned
it because he's a child and it's funny
um and then she was like that's some
real snake [ __ ]
like she got real cranky on a child it's
like stay
i i don't understand why what is it with
like hip-hop pop stars who don't
understand that you don't need to be
private messaging a child that's into
stranger things drake leave that little
girl alone uh dozia leave that little
boy alone stay out of the dms of miners
it's such a power i think that's a
message we can all get behind yeah to
become a celebrity and then suddenly
like instagram is just your personal
like any you're just like i'm a
celebrity i'm allowed in those dm's i'm
like some people can't handle all that
power they just like lose it right away
and we had just forgiven her for racial
foot chat and now this
huh
oh it's all i'll tell you all there it's
so
okay let's speed through this i want to
i want to hear that um all right keep
going and stranger things took that to
heart last night we couldn't even take
one group picture because there was like
50 of us i was like you need to start
killing people they just need to have
one massacre scene as always there's
millie bobby brown's 11 who's still
getting more nose weights than a horny
anime guy
watch her get bullied at regular school
and xavier's academy for gifted
youngsters putting the young actress
through more pain and abuse than the
time she went on hot ones my face
doesn't feel like my face
there's also i suggest that ever well i
love hot ones so you should watch it
just because it's fun but um the actor
who plays will uh takes a huge l on that
show because he he comes on camera while
she's doing hot ones and she's basically
like
and he's like oh it's not that hot like
this wing is fine and millie bobby
brown's like you weren't invited to do
this show beat it like yeah nobody wants
to watch you eat wings they want to
watch me eat wings
my favorite part of that is like why
would you do this to me i'm just a
little guy i'm just small
her english accent like i know she's
really brilliant i'm not saying i don't
think she's really british but for some
reason her english accent sounds faker
to me than when she's doing an american
like
bobby brown
where she does it the whole movie but
like i don't know it always throws me
every time a british voice comes out of
her yeah i think it's one of those
things when you are forced to do
and she has a great american accent when
you are forced to like learn to do the
american accent like that young it
starts like bleeding in almost like
she's almost reverse madonna right
exactly she's got that sound of an
american doing a british accent but
she's not she's from there i'm not a
truther i believe she's from there we
should do a game of uh secretly british
because there's more more and more
people every day are secretly british
and i for one have had enough
all right yeah keep playing then catch
up with mike will jonathan and an
enchanted bong who came to life that's a
funny word man
for an indie road trip dramedy about
that unforgettable
i do think it would have been an amazing
twist if at the end
lights are going out here
wave your arms around
uh if at the end uh uh jonathan was like
thank you argyle and the other kids are
like who's our kyle
or like they they killed back there and
arc i was like all right my work on this
planet it's done man and then he just
like disappears yeah
anyways that's all uh keep going we're
gonna go
in the back of a van plus there's lucas
and max he's pretending not to be a nerd
while we're pretending an 80s trailer
park kid likes kate bush more than
skinnard
[Music]
and don't forget dustin steve erica
robin nancy blossom jughead and guild or
this exposition gang is here to speed
run us through all the nerdy lore the
upside down
the demogorgon was just his foot soldier
that's his five-star general while
protecting an absolute legend named
eddie munson this metalhead with a heart
of gold must stay one step ahead of a
terrible curse being a fan favorite
newcomer on stranger things
[Music]
dang it again justice for eddie you too
chrissy you too newspaper twerp
you too other bully
had enough characters well um so the
yeah they kill off uh everyone's
favorite person but at the end i i i was
unclear can eleven raise the dead now
um like with max like did she bring her
back to life
it's unclear i feel like we don't we
don't quite know how max is gonna work
apparently what the duffers have since
said is that the original plan was just
max's dead and then at like a
last-second audible they were like nah
it's gonna really upset people
we'll leave her in a coma and let it
linger and we'll decide next year what
to do so i feel like it could be that
max is now going to be some sort of like
conduit to the like that will be
important that she's still connected to
the upside down in some way so maybe
it's it's that instead but it otherwise
yeah it does kind of seem like she
discovered a new force power she's got
that like rey force healing
that's so revealing is that they decided
to change course because they realized
that would upset people and it's like
you're
ostensibly making drama like upsetting
people means it's working like you're
affecting them
no
look you just got to get up
the duffer's got to stop reading the
comments like y'all got to get off
twitter right i feel like
people reacted so negatively to the barb
thing they were like oh
they love these characters they don't
want us to kill anybody and so now they
like on our horror show invent one
character a year as like fodder like all
right we'll kill sean astin but
everybody else all the legacy characters
that everybody likes get to live and
like i don't and and i saw that they
were like there could be stakes without
depth and i totally agree with that like
i don't think you need to kill
characters for there to be stakes
i think you need to kill some of these
characters because there's just freaking
too many characters and if you want to
keep following all these people we got
to start thinning the herd a bit it's
just like ridiculous now yeah you don't
even have to kill him off you could just
we we could just stop following joyce
and hopper like that's okay like i just
assume like all the other adults on
stranger things like they're just kind
of uninterested in whatever they're
doing they went back to their lives yeah
well it's because also now we're doing
these like redundancy things like so you
still have hopper who was in the first
season he was there to be the chief of
police like that was you need a chief of
police and hawkins to be like what's
going on ghosts ah that doesn't sound
right uh but now they've introduced not
only rob morgan as the new chief of
police but john reynolds as his like
maine officer deputy whatever
and you still have hopper like we keep
doing that in every like there was one
bully and now there's eight bullies and
there was like there was one cool older
friend and now there's 12 cool older
friends and it's like you gotta you
can't introduce all the new people
without calling some of the older people
or it just becomes ungainly
agreed yeah
all right i want one of those like uh
you know those uh simpsons episodes
where it just focuses on everyone we've
met around the town i just want like one
of those with everyone in hawkeye yeah
it feels like star trek but they want
you to get to know everybody on the
enterprise it's like no a lot of those
people are just in shirts in their
background like you don't have to worry
about them
skinner your oven's on fire it's just
the upside down
yeah just a portal
yeah 22 short stories about hawkins yeah
all right keep going characters well too
bad because most of the adults are still
alive too
and they're slogging through cuttable
plotlines like my two lab dads you don't
understand what he's capable of this is
not our choice whether she wants to stay
or go right doc
the great russian trope off yesterday
the fact that we know anything about um
yuri and uh what's the other guy's name
the yakun hagar i call him enzo enzo
yeah
all minutes of my life i will never have
back and like they are just there to
get joyce to hopper and then get them
out and the fact that they that they
spent any time we're like
we really need to know
about like where these guys come from
and their history and whether he's a
coward or not and will he overcome the
stigma about the peanut butter smuggler
like
what
why am i watching this
what is happening where are the children
and the the eventual connection like the
payoff at the end of the season for all
this stuff is like him killing these
monsters in the soviet union is going to
somehow
help the kids and like we you know it
sort of tangentially has suggested that
it helps but like it's so thin
it's almost like why even bother just
like
establish that murray and joyce are
going there to save him and then have
him come back at the end of the season
you don't need all that other stuff i
really feel like it's there to make it
feel more you know epic and bigger and
like you've seen this more
elaborate season play out but like
i guess i just feel like when they had
the whole of um if you have to include
hopper and uh the soviet union and joyce
and stuff like that like there are way
better 80s movies to steal from like if
that's their thing like just steal from
a better movie than whatever they were
doing there i just i don't know
i don't really know if that was stolen
from me it just feels like it's so it's
a lot of like i mean it's a lot of
generic like prison tropes but it's just
like it just felt perfunctory and it
felt like it felt padded it felt like
okay he gets out and then it's like oh
but it was a betrayal and they're
waiting for you and now you go right
back in it's like what's the point of
all that if you're just gonna end up
right back where you started right but
if you wanted to drop like an 80s action
movie into the middle of stranger things
like that was your chance but
no big flop no not really um
all right and i would suggest beverly
hills cop i just want to see a bunch of
bananas and tailpipes
david harbor getting thrown into the
street through a pain glass window
i'm gonna die someday
but not today a character who should be
dead but someone wanted to watch david
harbor get tortured
[Applause]
like a lot
stop stop stop he wasn't that bad in the
hellboy remake let's seal it with a kiss
okay just one more die
[Music]
but hopper is not the only lumbering
bald monster i should apologize because
uh i actually haven't seen the hellboy
remake i just assumed it was bad you've
seen it right lon yeah i uh look
it's got some problems and and the i
feel like it's one of those that's like
their their eyes were a lot bigger than
their budget like it's it's very
ambitious in terms of creature effects
and the sets and everything and it
doesn't
get there and so i think a lot of people
hold that like strongly against it and
it does like a lot of it looks gross i
i'll be first with it but i do i think
they're it's not the movie i don't think
is the worst ever and i think there are
some kind of cool fun ideas that feel
like cowboy comics in there it's just
you gotta wade through a lot of like
paul w s anderson level effects were to
get to it
all right yeah justice for hellboy uh
we'll maybe we'll rewatch i think you
got it's like i think morbius is a lot
worse like like cowboys aiming a lot
higher than morbius and i give it credit
for that but it's not it's not a total
success at all i don't feel bad making
fun of it in this way
that's all we ask
these licks come on
keep going
there's vecna a psychic with the wettest
tentacles you've ever seen squelch
after eleven send him to the upside down
and burn his dick off skeletor's cousin
who had too much work done is back for
revenge and he'll get it in a five step
seven day long process for killing one
kid that feels pretty inefficient for
america these days
i'll throw on 20 rounds bug shot for you
but it's the first high we've seen an
even matchup
i i thought that was just such a such
quintessential americana where it's like
all these teenagers are running into
each other at the gun store yeah we're
all buying guns at the same time
don't you hate it when that happens yeah
and so it was i weirdly too there was
this one chunk that felt very 70s in the
middle of the the stranger things 80
show where it was like they're all like
covered in grime and piling into this
like winnebago to go to the gun store
and james taylor's playing in the way
there and then they get to the gun store
and rock and roll hoochie coo is on like
the most 70s song
and it was like wait is this stranger
things or are we doing dukes of hazard
now
somebody put on some neon i'm lost and
confused
leg warmers and the aerobics tapes folks
come on
uh all right keep going number 11 as
long as you overlook his only two
weaknesses
music and friendship no
they're using the body system
it
burns so get ready for more cozy
benchable comfort food that you would
have stopped watching years ago if it
weren't for your parasocial relationship
with the cast as netflix beg you to
stick with them through their awkward
phase you're grown
yeah
and if we keep our subscriptions until
the next earnings report they can
pretend it's 2020 again
come on guys stick around it's just 10
to 20 bucks a month even cheaper once we
feel full of that
don't you want to know if this is cake
no
you'll be back for season five
starring uh
yeah you guys watch it as a cake i feel
like that's cake i think i think what do
you think
that one so we should bring that back up
on the screen if you if you have a
chance i'm pretty i'm pretty sure this
one this one feels like it's kicking me
i i i'm like uh
like 50 50 on is it cake you know it
it's uh i'm not perfect whether or not
you like it or 5050. no whether or not
whether or not things are cake yeah i'm
very curious this is one of those rare
things where i wonder if you're in the
studio if it's easier or harder i would
be harder i got right i feel like it
would be more challenging if you were
like that's good because you're like far
right here we're closer
this is cake i think yeah yeah
you can tell by the the edge right there
yeah it's the base that doesn't look
like the base you know yeah that's
definitely cake um
well this has been fun
it's much easier to play along with this
one at home than flora's lava
yeah yeah um because
for is a cake they can they can adjust
the lighting um
and you've got mikey day distracting you
you know
not ideal cake spotting conditions have
you seen it was on quibby now it's on
roku dismantled
titus burgess hosts that one that's hey
chefs and they put you in a blindfold
and they put you in an isolation booth
and then they use a food cannon to shoot
a dish at you
and you have to what are we doing you
have to taste the food as it's shot at
you and then recreate that dish like
guess what the food was what are we
doing create it this is a real show it's
unruly content
dismantled yeah well sometimes it's easy
where it's like oh there's pesto in this
it must be and then they make a pesto
but like other times it's just like ah
sea bass i don't know yeah i feel like
i'd be too um
traumatized by having food shot at my
face i'd be like i don't know what just
happened you just shot food at me right
they should call it yum shot
so
there's a japanese show that uh
i prefer to is it cake because i think
the steaks are a little higher um i
don't know what it's called but there
somebody is put in a room where certain
objects are made of food and other
things oh right they have to guess with
their mouth right like there's no they
can't touch it with their hands they
have to take a bite and uh and find out
what's what so yeah why can't they just
adapt that um
all right i'm sure they will they'll get
up to be next year
take this l
how many fins could a wolf hard wolf if
a thin wolf could wolf hard you can't
put that haircut on a grown man it's
cruel dusty the clown
cliques and geeks stephen king
nan helsing
this one time at band camp buyers
remorse my only regret is that i have
bone itis two years away from starring
in beetlejuice
this is what happens when you pirate
metallica kids nina papa always gets
paid
venti
like wow scoob yak win the ussr
and the duffer brothers one rule for
their core characters everything works
out happy ending for everybody
epic real time
okay i'll just say it jason had every
reason to think the last person seen
alive with his dead girlfriend a drug
dealer who went into hiding was a
murderer but hey kind of an app for not
being caught up in the lore sure
pause uh he kind of has a few seconds to
like get up there i i have my issues
with the pacing of that final shot where
we're following the like lava flow right
up to his gut like if you see
like the
literally the ground is splitting open
into a fiery crevasse and he was tied
down by something by
a squelching tentacle i don't remember
is there a squelching tentacle they let
us know in the comments holding them
down
you gotta like lunge in one or the other
direction man you can't just lay
perfectly i assume this will work out i
think they would have given him a more
gratuitous death scene given that he was
like the big the big bad bully yeah
that's another thing where it's like
we follow him so consistently throughout
the season that he's going to be this
huge threat and then he like delays
lucas by a few minutes like it's really
like what was the point of all of that
and look i'm obviously being very uh
troll-ish by by doing any kind of
justice for for jason thing but i do
think that if your girlfriend
dies and the last person she was with
disappears he's a drug dealer you're
probably like okay that guy killed her
uh i'm going to find him um and
obviously not good to round up a posse
and take the law into your own hands but
then again
when you when you come across uh
you find you finally track them down and
somebody is definitely in a trance
and again it's like okay
they're probably the bad guys um so if
he acts like meatloaf in rocky horror
all the time they're like there's
something off about this guy i don't
know yeah
uh production of rocky horror right now
this is just high school yeah
uh all right let's do some uh delete
scenes see what else we got in there
starring
she's a 10 but with one more added on
millie baldy brown
joanne the scanner
gosh dang it millie bobby go to your
room tell you what that girl ain't right
wolf hard with a vengeance lackluster
afterlife
superhero fetish
summer of bowl
coming out that will
likes mike
scary in the hendersons angel dust dust
busting
kid at play
ballers jock jams kiri indiana
from batman ah batsman
wheeler and dealer
editor in grief
hall girl
the dream warrior
save the last trance oh dejoyce the
multiverse of momness
[Music]
in soviet russia reason escapes you
dungeon master of puppets shredding
crashers cried into the dms
modine bow problems
one flay at a time
mind hunter
clock king
creel of dreams
literal spider-man
you ever watch stranger things on weed
yank off kirkland brand vodka
yuri the worst we come to this place for
magic
has nothing to say about your black
friend for playing basketball you saying
sinclair's been taken in by the dark
side uh something like that
kate bush v gore yeah that was in
context where they're like yeah lucas is
he doesn't want to do nerdy stuff
anymore he just wants to play basketball
so he's gone to the dark side
wow way to go dude oh man i don't know
something weird about this guy i don't
know hope he doesn't murder our most
popular classmate
[Laughter]
oh man eddie eddie will be back trust me
he's they'll find a way after this the
duffers will be like uh just kidding
he's in the upside down yeah he's now a
bat man
um all right let's 13 hours the secret
child soldiers of hawkins
i think you should grieve
stranger things season more
there are factions within our government
who are working directly against eleven
yeah but like does it matter
so no then cool thanks
does not matter
yeah we spend all that for nothing i
guess it'll pay off next season right
presumably i mean next season is after a
time jump so that guy is standing there
on the side of the road in the desert
for like two years
he's shaking his fists yeah
all right uh we're gonna move on to take
some uh questions but before that thank
you for watching um please like please
subscribe please hit the ding ling and
uh you'll never miss another thing we do
similarly uh there's a fandom twitch
channel i know we keep threatening to do
uh live watch longs but we'll we'll get
one of those going this summer um so we
can all hang out and watch movies
together which sounds like fun but right
now it's twitch tv twitch.tv backslash
fandom check it out subscribe there's
already good honest game trailer stuff
up there and other things um now on to
your questions um
greta genie says honest trailers is my
comfort food my junk food and my
background noise haha uh greetings from
bogota colombia don't you dare say
colombia uh i do think friendship and
music could save the world that's
awesome they
seem cool um
i uh i also shout out to colombia which
is the only place uh my kid wants to
live after watching um in kanto
for the last year and a half of this so
obsessed with colombia but she probably
thinks think like magic is real there
you go
magic yeah yeah you gotta jump right
that way yeah you might wanna like like
all those delicious foods you see we can
go try but like not there's no magic out
yeah like we could just have arepas here
probably but no we'll not settle for
that um
uh
let's see um
pat mcgonna asks uh
why didn't we do the trailer for seasons
two and three um i don't remember i
don't know why we don't remember either
i was thinking about this i thought the
first one we did was both seasons
seasons one and two but maybe it was
timed but yeah i couldn't remember why
we did yeah
i thought we here's your answer i don't
know yeah i don't i mean we were i was
already working on an honest trailer was
when three came out i don't know what
our i don't remember us even having a
conversation
yeah
so sometimes things just slip through
the cracks and uh tv is obviously a
bigger commitment than movies so like
yeah i feel like right we just and there
were more movies then yeah yeah we just
did less tv then generally yeah was that
blockbuster summer i'm trying to
remember it might have been
um so peterson roberto da silva says uh
i'd love to know uh all of our opinion
on the length of the last episode
i mean i'm fine with it it's just
in context of the whole season there
were just plot lines that we didn't need
i think that we all agree
joyce and hopper and all the government
faction stuff and a lot of the van a lot
of the van time could just be lost with
no
real hit to the overall quality of that
season and it would have been
10 hours instead of 13 and i think that
would have made a big difference
yeah i mean that's that's basically how
i i just i feel like every season of
stranger things is is format wise
basically the same
like meet some new characters catch up
with everybody there's a new threat 11
needs to recharge her powers in order to
face it and then at the end they face
off it looks like it's gone but we get a
little clue that maybe not totally gone
coming back and
that's fine i think it's okay for tv
shows to do that but then you don't keep
growing in size and portent every time
because we could start to see through it
it doesn't feel as epic because we kind
of know where it's all going and that's
how i felt by the final episode it
wasn't that like i don't i think you
could justify a two and a half hour
season finale length they just maybe
don't
yeah yeah
um all right keith frazier says a
question for the panel is netflix really
having a crisis collapse or whatever or
is it just that they're no longer one of
only two really big streaming services
this is a great point i think this is a
really good question but to that i say
like the you know
potato potato cause it's like they
they are spending in order to become
like the only option or at least a
must-have option when it comes to
streaming services so any amount of
attrition is like catastrophic for them
they are built around the premise that
they will
have everybody in the world sign up for
netflix so if they're not growing they
are dying uh as at least according to
their you know to the investors right
and it is one of those things that you
have to remember that a lot of these
other streaming services like the
streaming service is something in
addition to something they already do
successfully like
max is they already have hbo amazon is
already amazon netflix this is like the
only thing that they do is this there
isn't like another they don't like sell
books um and if they did y'all wouldn't
read them but they don't do anything
else and so that's why like this is so
important for them where it's obviously
it's important for everyone else too but
you know peacock is nbc like they they
like if any of those services don't
necessarily
um aren't number one they've got another
thing it's like when um
sony and microsoft entered the console
wars and it's like nintendo all they do
is games but like sony and microsoft can
afford to take hits on stuff before the
gaming started getting really profitable
because they had all of these other
things that they were doing it's like
ricky bobby said if you're not first
you're last you're also at a point where
the those top three like like netflix
disney plus hbo max at this point it's
just new markets like they're they're
launched in a lot of the world people in
those markets have had years to decide
so i want netflix so i want to give up
my netflix to get this one i want that
one so there's just like we're getting
to the point now where the kind of lines
are sort of drawn and any big change is
significant like there was just this
whole big thing about who's going to get
indian premier league cricket rights
just because they're now
you know there's there's that's a huge
front in the streaming wars is like the
indian market because the american
market is like we're kind of all we've
all picked already like maybe there'll
be a new thing or like a few people will
change per year like oh i'm going to get
paramount to watch star trek shows and
i'm going to leave amazon because i
don't care about these shows whatever
but like
at this point a lot of it comes down to
just well where are you launching next
you know and like we got to open up in
malaysia we got to get the middle east
or like when are we going to sub-saharan
africa and like trying to hit those last
remaining markets yeah i mean in a world
that makes sense uh it's okay to stop
growing and to just be where you're at
and make something good for the people
who are already signed on but that's
just not our issues that's our world and
yeah the stock people are always
watching you know who's growing fastest
and attrition rates and all that for the
stock which is really what this is all
about yeah
um all right uh we can
end on uh this besides stranger things
and the oc which show had the best glow
up after a drop um and i
uh i agree with you the the the oc had a
had a down season but i enjoyed i
enjoyed every single one of them um but
i think that uh for me the obvious one
is friday night lights gonna say it you
took it right out of my mouth he's in
season two when mtv gave the note of
like maybe maybe um
uh jesse plummer should kill somebody
and then it just becomes this like super
campy uh uh teen drama for about six
episodes in the middle of season two and
then it then it gets back on track
that's worth a re-watch right i haven't
seen that in like 10 years it's worth a
re-watch for yeah i've never i've
actually never i've never seen that oh
it's like the nucleus of like so many
great uh actors uh that we have today
right yeah yeah for sure i was gonna say
uh twin peaks is kind of a classic
example where the first season and the
beginning of season two so amazing and
you had lynch and frost both firing on
all cylinders and then abc forces them
to reveal laura palmer's killer lynch
kind of loses interest and starts doing
other stuff so takes a definite sort of
mid-season two
crater where there's just a run of
episodes that are clearly less
interesting than theirs but then lynch
came back and they closed on a real like
the last few episodes of twin peaks
season two were like
wow amazing uh so i would say that one
like like real finish on a real high and
then of course you've got the return and
all those other it returned to great
yeah
all right um well sweet uh there's a lot
of uh lore questions uh that have also
come in but i don't know
what is what is vecna going to do now
and like where where is what's max's
role going to be in season five yeah i
have no idea um i don't even know if
they know
i feel like they know where it all and
like i feel like they probably got an
end point in mind i don't think they
know how they get there yet no not with
the name like the duffer brothers come
on
what do they know uh change that name
that's that's my first note
you gotta yeah punch that up uh next
week we will be back uh i'm very excited
for this um
here's your clue uh it's related to thor
four but maybe not in the way you'd
think
that's that's your clue i'm gonna go
ahead and say definitely not it the way
you think yeah yeah a little offbeat
choice we've done some big uh some big
popular things this one's just for us
and just for you the audience here at uh
commentaries thank you danielle thank
you lon for hanging out with me here at
the studio hope to see you in person
next week hope everyone's feeling better
and yeah we'll see you then bye
[Music]
you